[Musique]
un vaccin contre le nouveau corner virus
at il véritablement été découvert
permettez moi d'en douter
méfiez-vous des publications virales
comme celle ci qui affirme que le vaccin
contre le virus est déjà presque prêt et
qu'il aurait été créé par des
scientifiques américains
ma collègue bouchra what i khas
décortiquée avec attention cette
publication d'abord vous aurez peut être
remarqué qu il y est écrit virus caronna
déjà là yang et sous roche
ensuite tout ça est faux parce que la
toute première étude clinique sur un tel
vaccin a commencé il y à peine une
dizaine de jours aux états unis
et soyons patients les experts estiment
qu'il faudra au moins un an avant que le
vaccin soit disponible à grande échelle
si on porte maintenant attention la
photo qui accompagne la publication
elle montre une boîte d'un produit
pharmaceutique où on peut lire le mot
covè 19 le produit sur l'image est en
fait une trousse de dépistage qui sert
donc à déterminer si une personne est
porteuse ou non du strass cov 2019
c'est à dire le virus qui causent la
coved 19 la même image de trausse de
dépistage sachets leur a été utilisé
dans une autre publication trompeuses ou
au prétend que la france vient de
développer un vaccin contre le coroner
virus
petit problème oui plusieurs projets de
recherche sont en cours à travers le
monde pour développer un vaccin mais les
experts estiment comme je l'évoquais
tantôt qu'il faudrait entre 12 et 18
mois avant qu'un vaccin soit prêt autre
indice que la publication est fausse on
dit que ce présumé vaccin pourrait
guérir les patients atteints dans les
trois heures suivant l'injection
c'est une affirmation qui fausse tout
simplement parce que les vaccins certes
à prévenir la maladie et non à la guérir
en fait ils sont carrément inutile si le
patient est déjà infectées dans ces cas
là le patient besoin non pas d'un vaccin
mais plutôt d'un traitement je vous
invite à lire l'article de bouchra
wathiq sur notre site web
n'oubliez pas aussi d'adhérer à notre
groupe facebook vous êtes déjà près de
14000 à l'avoir fait merci faut que ça
continue
une question sur ce qui circule sur le
web écrivez-nous décrypteurs au pluriel
à commercial radio tirait canada.ca
salut
[Musique]